why why
just why warning do not use your
sparkling water maker for anything other
than carbonating water
use of the sparkling water maker for any
unintended purposes
may result in serious personal injury
all right it's time to do some science
or i guess what can pass for science
when you're not a scientist look i got a
bunch of liquids i want to see if they
carbonate and so i'm going to take you
along with me while i carbonate all this
stuff and rank them because not all
carbonated beverages are built the same
i
as someone that's built different should
be able to rank these things
so the reason i wanted to do all this in
the first place is because i used to
drink a lot of this stuff and i always
wondered to myself
what would this be like bubbly yes that
was like 10 years ago
but i've kept wondering it the whole
time and i'm really excited to find out
science isn't about why it's about why
not
oh god oh foamy foamy
i've only just realized how messy this
video is gonna be while i won't say it
made it better
it definitely didn't make it worse this
is a tear carbonation
what's next let's add some bubbles to
bubble tea
using the straw as a knife as
god intended there we go oh god
oh no okay it's just dripping a little
bit
it's fine we're fine everything's fine
oh that's way worse oh i should not go
no no no there's enough bubbles in boba
as it is
stick with the bubbles that are already
there it kind of tastes like a bad
root beer float oh this gets a d because
i can't say it made me
throw up i think jello is a liquid yeah
see let's see if it carbonates
i'm absolutely destroying flubber right
now what a great movie that's the kind
of movie that would never be made today
this is so jiggly it's like my butt this
is probably some asmr for someone listen
and for everyone else i'm sorry i'm not
so sure this one's gonna work there's no
knowing until we try
look at him jiggle okay let's try this
this didn't even carbonate at all i just
made the jello jiggle as far as foods go
i love jello i would give it an a as far
as carbonated things go
uh this is an f because it it just
didn't carbonate
mademoiselle would you like some
champagne
yep that certainly is a 10 bottle of
wine let's see if this makes it any
better
oh god no no no no no who knew making
champagne was so messy okay we lost like
half of the wine
[Music]
champagne for me it's actually not
terrible
it's not horribly far away from
champagne
i think that that aerated the line a
little bit it released the tannins
bee bee i think i need some more alcohol
to follow that up
whiskey time never in my entire life
have i thought to myself
wow this whiskey's really good but you
know what it could be
bubblier oh that's bubbly whiskey
what do you know i would never ask for
this or want it again
absolutely not f minus g h
i i don't know just never let me have
that ever again
i'm gonna go lie down for just five
minutes
physically i've recovered but mentally i
may never i never said these had to be
beverages just liquids
pretty average pasta sauce i think this
is going to work a bit better than jello
it is more of a liquid it's definitely
thick a thick wood if you will
oh that's weird there's only one way i
can really determine if this is good
and that's to put it on some noodles
this isn't a flavor experience this is a
sensory
experience i'm sure there's some weird
experimental chef
that would serve you carbonated pasta
sauce for like eight hundred dollars a
plate
and i'm telling you don't pay that make
it at home you'll only be slightly
disappointed
as a solid seed i wouldn't eat it again
but it's not making me feel sick which
is a low bar but it's the one we're at
right now
this is the one i'm most scared for i
don't know if you've ever heard of thick
water
i wish i hadn't it's viscous water it's
somewhere between water and lube that's
not appealing all right i gotta just try
this
smells like nothing
oh my god i'm getting something i can
throw up into because i have
a very strong feeling i'm going to puke
oh
look at how slowly that pours
oh dear lord okay i gotta get off
quickly
oh no that looks
if i sit here long enough will it go
away
oh my god it's disgusting
but it improved it neither of them are
good i'm giving them both f's but this
gets an f
plus it took one of the worst things
i've ever
experienced gastronomically and it made
it slightly
slightly tolerable it's just so
slimy remember you are not supposed to
swallow mouthwash so i am just doing
this for the
feeling i want to feel something
cool oh
i can't get it off don't use this with
mouthwash
do not okay oh goodness
f f f f f i hate mouthwash and that was
just
i hate you go away never come back
mouthwash all right this abomination
that some people like to call maple
syrup
is not maple syrup but if you accept it
for what it is thick sugar water
it can be tolerable i refuse to call it
maple syrup as a vermont boy it would be
blasphemous
let's see if we can break it
sorry i was having an existential crisis
d anything's better than mouthwash
honestly now i can see that
very sweet it's like thick coke have you
wanted to choke on some thick coke now
you can't
for the low low price of 2.99 we're
almost there
i kind of want to just remember what
seltzer water tastes like so
oh it's so neutral so perfect s tear no
contest
oh that's hot i love hot sauce i i like
hot spicy things
but this this might break me
there we go oh boy
why why
just why
f don't add bubbles to hot sauce just
don't do it
it's like oh you know that thing that
hurts to eat you want to make it more
painful
wow dakota what a great video idea you
had here just want to torture yourself
apparently
we finally arrived at the last thing
milk this is still dripping which makes
me think that this milk is going to be
spicy
all right we all know what milk tastes
like delicious to me
a plus to your beverage to some f minus
to your beverage
i love milk i'm sorry i'm probably
lactose intolerant and i'm definitely
carbonated lactose intolerant
i'm scared and it only smells a little
bit like hot sauce and mouthwash
that's just rotten milk how has this
taken milk that was perfectly fresh and
instantly spoiled it it's like barely
bubbly it just tastes sour
i bought some chocolate sauce to
hopefully like try and make it better
but like oh
as it sits this is a d let's add
chocolate sauce see if it's any better
carbonated chocolate milk
okay i can get behind that that's that's
good you ever have an egg cream this
basically tastes exactly like an egg
cream carbonated chocolate milk
the chocolate helps everything so what
have we learned here today we've learned
that carbonated iced tea
slaps and we've learned that carbonating
anything else is a bad idea
leave it to the professionals they know
what to do just use the soda stream for
water add flavors after the fact
don't try to stick anything else in it
please for the love of god you're gonna
ruin your sodastream and yourself
i am ruined i am broken and i need a nap
thank you so much for watching
sodastream please do not send me a cease
and desist
you